you might have heard the uproar in march
2021 over the decision to stop
publishing six dr seuss books for
racially insensitive imagery
while this may not be a tremendous loss
to literature one of those books could
claim a notable linguistic
accomplishment
if i ran the zoo published in 1950
contains the first written instance of
the word
nerd when authors create words for a
one-time usage they're known as
nonce words though it kind of sounds
like nonsense
the word nonce is actually a cognate of
once
as in words to be used only once however
sometimes these single usage words can
pick up steam
becoming neologisms terms that are still
new and limited to certain fields
and perhaps some of those will
eventually make their way into our
shared vocabulary as
full-fledged words becoming so common
that we totally forget their literary
origins
i'm dr erica brazovsky and this is other
[Music]
words
other words
okay if we're talking about authors
creating words we have to address the
600 pound gorilla that barred himself
william shakespeare at one time he was
credited with inventing over 2
000 english words though that number has
dwindled in recent years
turns out he was such a prolific writer
that his works were just the first place
many scholars had seen these words
but it's likely many were already in
common usage at the time
for instance dwindle was first in henry
iv
part one shakespeare's lexical
creativity was
more about finding new and ingenious
ways to use existing words
you would combine them giving us bedroom
outbreak and cold-blooded
he would change nouns into verbs so
gossip and elbow went from being
things to actions you could do and he
was absolutely extravagant with prefixes
and suffixes
sprinkling uns and ebolas all over the
place
not all of his creations caught on but
he turned out verbal innovations with
such regularity
it's not surprising that we still use
many today
well before shakespeare the english poet
jeffrey chaucer
famous for his canterbury tales wanted
to describe the light
tremulous call an encaged bird makes as
it yearns for freedom
and came up with the onomatopoeia
twitter
700 years later we're the encaged birds
tweeting our takes into the void
in 1667 john milton published paradise
lost
an epic poem in origin story of the
ultimate archvillain
satan he envisioned hell having a
capital city which he named pandemonium
the meeting has shifted since then to
describe a state of chaos where all hell
is broken loose
but the original literal definition was
the place where all the demons lived
by the way arch villain is one of
shakespeare's creations
a couple hundred years later sir walter
scott was writing his chivalric romance
ivanhoe considered a major influence on
the modern version of the robin hood
story he wanted a new term for hired
mercenaries
soldiers without loyalty to any banner
whose lances were free to fight for
whoever could pay the most
so he called them freelancers and the
term caught on to describe people who
work job to job for different clients
it's definitely more colorful than the
lackluster contractor
but still a weirdly violent term for
someone who designs corporate logos
oh and lackluster another one of
shakespeare's
lewis carroll's poem jabberwocky is a
multitudinous sea of non-words
okay will we get it many were created by
melding two existing words together to
get something that
almost sounds like a word you already
know for instance
chortle is a combination of chuckle and
snort
and galumph was supposedly a triumphant
gallop
both of these words managed to transcend
wonderland's borders into the english
dictionary
i guess if you buy that many lottery
tickets you're gonna win something
when preparing his 1840 volume the
philosophy of the inductive sciences
reverend william hewell wanted a single
word to refer to a practitioner of the
scientific method
and he came up with scientist just think
if he gone a different way we might be
calling them sciencers or
science myths or scientifician
speaking of scientists when physicist
murray gellman theorized the existence
of subatomic particles in 1964
he named them quarks inspired by a nonce
word that james joyce came up with for
his 1939 novel finnegan's wake
like most of joyce's writing i have no
idea what the original meeting was
supposed to be
in 1920 cuddle chapeck wrote a science
fiction play about humanoid machines
constructed to perform
manual tasks he borrowed a czech term
for forced labor
and robot quickly left the world of
science fiction
to describe real-life automated machines
that work for us
on a related note most people think that
droid
originated in 1977 star wars but its
first appearance was
actually in the 1952 short story robots
of the world arise
by mariwolf i don't know if this counts
as a new
word though since it's really just a
shortening of android which comes from
the greek for
man-shaped also lucasfilm trademarked
the term so if another author wanted to
use it they'd have to cough up some
republic credits for it
moving from sci-fi to fantasy j.r.r
tolkien
used the word tween to describe the
period in a hobbit's life between
childhood
and adulthood roughly 20 to 33.
today we use it to refer to
pre-adolescence because of its
similarity to teen
since teenager wasn't really popularized
until the late 1950s
tolkien was probably just shortening
between or combining it with twenties
however hobbits did live over a hundred
years so maybe the definition hasn't
changed that much
one more scientifician for you in 1976
is the selfish gene
biologist richard dawkins wanted to
express how culture could be shaped by a
process not unlike
natural selection that ideas and
thoughts could survive and
replicate based on their fitness he
needed a word for a unit of culture that
could spread
so he took the greek word for imitation
and condensed it to sound like the word
gene though now we mostly use this term
to mean visual jokes that you post
online
it originally meant any shareable idea
style or behavior
from religious beliefs to fashion trends
to new words that means the word meme
is a meme like biological genetics it
can be very difficult to discern why
some nods were survived and spread while
others didn't
why did nerd become a household word and
not its neighbors preep
prue and knurkle maybe it just sounds
better
though some suspect sue simply stumbled
on a slang for nut
that was already becoming popular it's
impossible to know today
yes will you can take credit for
household word
one thing is certain a single writer can
coin a word
but they can't make it popular all of us
collectively
through our behavior and interactions
get to decide what becomes a real word
and what stays literary not sense
[Music]
but its first appearance was actually
in the night but it's first appeared
ah i need to like make sure i'm not
crying okay